λιάδε ρα οπτε απότο δύος λιστεσερα δούλευα στην κύπρο στον τωμένον ται λ επικοινωνιών μου
στην έριξον για ευτά χρόνια και μετάημου στην έμπτια για πέντε χρόνια οπότε με μια
καλήθυτία σες τηλεπικοινώνίες σίγουρα είχα φιλοδοξίες στων τομένων το λπικοινωνίων και για να μελικρίνεις καλύτεροι
ι δουλειά σες στη επικοινωνία στην κύπρο είναι αίσωση τη σύνα όπότε όταν άνοιξε αυτή
η θέση δεφθα σου κό ψέγματα πραγματικά πίστεψα ότι έχω ότι χρειάζζεται γι αυτή τη
θέση τη διεκδήκησα και την κέρδισα πτ από και και πέρα προσπαθώ να απόδείξω καθημερινά
και στων ευτό μου ότι είμαι ίσως αυτό και ησίήτα αξίζει να έχει σαν ιγιος
φυσικού αδεν κάνω λάθος γειατί ο αντριαςναο κλαίος δεν ακολούθησε αυτά τα μόνο πάτιανομίζω όλοι
όχι όλι αλλάρκαιτί από τους γιούς ίσως αποθέμαν αντίδρασης δεν ακολουθούμε της την μπορεία που
ακολούθησε ο πατέρας μας ίσως γιατί πιστεύουμε μέσα μας ότι μπορούμε να το κάνουμε καλύτερα
εγώ γεννικά η γωνίς μου ήταν εκπαιδευτική είναιείναι συνταξιούχη τώρα αλλά το μόνο επάγγελμα που
απέίκλια από την αρχή ήταν να γίνο εκπαιδευτικώς και ο λόγος ήταν τούτος δεν ήθελα
ν ακολουθήσω δ απορία το γόνιομου διότι και να ήταν άδεικον αυτον ίσως που λέω
τώρα δηλαδή τότε απλά έβλεπα μόνον τα αρνητικά πολλά από τα θετικά τα οποία είχε
ν αυτή η πορεία τώρα τα βλέπω τότε ήμουνανόριμος πότε έβλεπα ίσως το θέμα του
ότι η δουλειά μου φαινόταν ερκετά βαρετ η ρουτήνα ήταν πάρα παραπολύ συνηθισμένη